معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس اضافه لما رصدناه في الساعه
الماضيه ما الجديد
لديك مياد القتال على اشده في مخيم البريج
وسريعا سننتقل الى المنطقه التي تعرضت الى
قصف من جانب القوات الاسرائيليه تشاهدين
هذه القنابل المضيئه الان التي تكرر
اطلاقها في الساعه الاخيره اكثر من مره
نشاهدها الان تعود الى مشهد هذه المعركه
بعد غاره جويه عنيفه كانت قبل لحظات قليله
قد استهدفت المناطق الوسطى لمخيم البريج
هذه ال القنابل المضيئه ربما تكون اشارات
من جانب القوات الاسرائيليه على الارض
هناك في الداخل لتوجيه المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لقصفها او لتوجيه الطائرات
المقاتله الحربيه لقصف هذه المنطقه او او
انها تكون مؤشرات ايضا لان قوه عسكريه
اسرائيليه باتت في مازق وهي تحتاج لغطاء
جوي او مدفعي او حتى لاجلاء جرحى مفترضين
في داخل صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا كثافه
القنابل المضيئه ويبدو ان هنالك ايضا
اطلاقات اخرى تاتي من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه تشي
بان هذه المعركه على اشدها وانها متواصله
وتتخذ زخم
كبيرا جدا في الساعه الاخيره اذا مزيد من
القنابل المضيئه كما نشاهدها الان هنا من
منطقه غلاف غزه وسط تحليق كثيف للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه التي تجوب اجواء المنطقه
وكذلك المسيرات الاسرائيليه التي تراقب
وترصد ما يجري في داخل هذا المخيم الذي
يشهد قتالا شرسا وعنيفا منذ اكثر من
ساعتين
اذا مزيد من القنابل المضيئه الغارات
الجويه كانت عنيفه جدا مياده في الساعه
الاخيره اكثر من غاره جويه استهدفت مناطقه
بعينها وسحب الدخان الاسود تنبعث من اماكن
متعدده في داخل المخيم وهذا يعني بان حتى
رقعه القتال ورقعه المواجهه هي كبيره وغير
محصوره فقط في منطقه بعينها هناك طيب
الياس هذه البقعه التي يتم الان فيها
اطلاق القنابل الضوئيه هل سبق استهدافها
بغارات او قصف مدفعيه اسرائيليه في
الساعات
الماضيه بالفعل هي المنطقه القريبه منها
نرى بعض الابنيه الصغيره ربما باللون
الابيض البعيده هذه المنطقه استهدفت قبل
نحو اقل من ساعه بغارتين جويتين عنيف ولحق
ذلك ايضا هذه القنابل المضيئه من جانب
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي تطلق هذه
القنابل المضيئه منذ اكثر من ساعه على تلك
المنطقه وهدف اطلاق هذه ال الاناره او
الاضاءه في هذه الساعه المبكره من الصباح
هي بطبيعه الحال تؤشر على ان هنالك قتالا
عنيفا يجري في الميدان لاننا نسمع ايضا
اشتباكات عنيفه بالرشاشات الثقيله تدور
رحاها في داخل ال المخيم ويبدو ان هنالك
ايضا استهدافات من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ل القوات الاسرائيليه الراجله
والمؤ لان الدخان الاسود المنبعث من اكثر
من منطقه في داخل المخيم ليس بالضروره ان
يكون ناجم عن القصف المدفعي العنيف على
هذه المنطقه او الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه انما يكون ناجم ربما عن
استهدافات ايضا من جانب المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للاليات العسكريه للدبابات
الميركافا ل ناقلات الجند من نوع نمير او
حتى للجرافات الاسرائيليه التي تعمل في
داخل
المخيم ولكن اللافت الان بياده هو ما يجري
في الاطراف ربما الجنوبيه
لمخيم البريج هذه قنابل الاضاءه التي تكاد
لا تتوقف والجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل اطلاق
المدفعيه وهذه القنابل المضيئه على تلك
المنطقه تحديدا التي يبدو انها ستشهد اما
قصفا مدفعيا شديدا او انها ستشهد ربما
ايضا مزيد من الغارات الجويه من جانب
الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي نحن نسمع في
الاجواء طيله الوقت تخليق كثيف للطائرات
الحربيه المقاتله من نوع اف 16 وكذلك
الطائرات المسيره التي ترصد وتراقب وتنقل
صوره الوضع في الميدان ولكن هذه المسيرات
ايضا بعضها قادر على توجيه ضربات صاروخيه
ايضا في داخل المخيم هذه المنطقه مياده
كان يفترض ان الجيش الاسرائيلي كما قالت
بياناته في الاسابيع الماضيه انه انجز
فيها العمليه العسكريه وانه قضى كما قال
على المسلحين الفلسطينيين لكن واضح من حجم
ما يجري من اشتباكات عنيفه ومن انفجارات
هائله ما زلنا نسمعها حتى الان ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما زالت تبدي باسا
قويا وشديدا الان هنالك غاره جويه او
انفجار انفجار اخر في منطقه جحر الديك
مياده هذه المنطقه تعرضت ايضا صباح هذا
اليوم لانفجارات
اي عنيفه جدا ليس واضحا اي احيانا لا لا
لا نتمكن من التاكيد فيما اذا كانت هذه
غارات جويه او انفجارات ناجمه عن تفجيرات
يتعمد الجيش الاسرائيلي القيام بها لان
هذه المنطقه التي يسلط عليها الزميل لبيب
الان عدسه الكاميرا هي منطقه قريبه جدا من
السياج الامن وبالتالي واضح بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتعمد احداث هذه التفجيرات وت
تدمير بنى مدنيه او بنى اي اقتصاديه تابعه
للفلسطينيين في هذه المناطق القريبه من
السياج الامني على اعتبار ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقوم بسياسه ممنهجه وكنا قد
اشرنا اليها في الاسابيع الماضيه وهي
عمليه تدمير واسعه لكل الابنيه والمواقع
ال العمرانيه للفلسطينيين في المناطق
الشرقيه
ل قطاع غزه اي تلك القريبه من السياج
الامني والتي يستهدف منها الجيش
الاسرائيلي افراغ هذه المنطقه و هدمها و
تدميرها ومسحها من ال من الوجود للحؤول
دون تمكن الفلسطينيين من العوده اليها بعد
انتهاء الحرب لان في مخططات الجيش
الاسرائيلي اقامه منطقه عازله كما يبدو في
هذه المنطقه تشكل عمقا امنيا واستراتيجيا
ل منطقه غلاف غزه وتحديدا للبلدات
الاسرائيليه القريبه من السياج الامني
غاره جديده الان مياده قريبه تقريب قريبا
من المنطقه التي كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يشير اليها من خلال الاضاءه وقنابل
القنابل مضيئه التي اشار اليها في تلك
المنطقه واضح تماما بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
في البريج في مازق كبير الان هنالك
مقاتلات اسرائيليه تدخل في اجواء القطاع
ويبدو انها ستغير مره اخرى سنرى اين ستكون
هذه الغاره لكن نسمع هدير الطائرات ابقي
معنا مياده
نعم اذا تسمعين هدير ال الطائرات التي
دخلت الان اجواء
اي نعم الان نسمع انفجار في داخل المخيم
سنرى ان كنا بالامكان تحديد موقع الغاره
الجويه لكن واضح بان الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي لا يغادر سماء هذه هي المنطقه
وهو الان اخترق اجواء البريج ويبدو ان هذه
الطائره غارت على منطقه في داخل المخيم او
في منطقه ما بين البريج صرات التي لا
نستطيع ان نراها من هذه المنطقه لكن واضح
بان المعركه على اشدها هنا مياده وواضح
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي في مازق كبير في هذه
المعركه لانه يست هذا الغطاء الجو
الكثيف والمدفعيه ايضا لتوفير غطاء له كما
سبق
نشرت البريج وكذلك حتى مخيمات اخرى نصرات
والمغازي وجحر الديك كانت يعني في قلب
العمليات العسكريه منذ ان توجهت نحو الوسط
والجنوب ولكن ان يعود بهذا الشكل وهذه
الكثافه هل يمكن القول ان
هناك استماته اسرائيليه الان اكثر مما سجل
في الايام الماضيه في هذه المناطق تحديدا
هم يحاولون يعني تحديد صوره نصر في هذه
الحرب وفي هذه المعركه ولم ينجحوا وكثير
من الخبراء العسكريين والمحللين العسكريين
في اسرائيل ومن كبار المحللين يقولون بان
اسرائيل المجلس الحربي الجيش الاسرائيلي
المستويين السياسي والعسكري في اسرائيل
فشلوا حتى الان في تحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب
التي اعلنت بشكل واضح من جانب مجلس الحرب
وهو القضاء على حركه حماس اي عسكريا
وسلطوية
هو الوحيد الذي كان قد توقع هجوم السابع
من اكتوبر بحذافيره وبالتالي كل ما يقوله
اصبح وكانه مقدس بين هلالين على الاقل لدى
الاعلام الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هو يقول
اليوم بان اسرائيل تراوح مكانها لم تحقق
الانجاز العسكري المرجو في القضاء على
حركه حماس وهي تزج الجيش الاسرائيلي
المنهك والمتعب في في حرب استنزاف ربما او
الغوص في في وحل غزه وهو يقول بان على
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يعيد انتشار قواته
على الاقل في منطقه خانيونس
لان وجود القوات في داخل المدينه اصبح
يعرض الجنود لمزيد من القتلى وال الجرحى
دون ان تنجز اسرائيل اهداف حربها في
القضاء على حماس عسكريا وسلطوية
الوزير ايزنكوت نشكرك جزي شكر من غلاف غزه
مراسل الجزيره الياس كر